This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档 I-Heart 播客节目。真人保证。百分之二。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《百分之二》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《百分之二》。搜索数字 2 percent，即可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在 Look Back at it 播客节目中。从 1979 年开始，这对我和我来说都是一个重要时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家。比如马可·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听 Look Back At It。嘿，大家近来如何？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个节目主要探讨黑人群体的切身经历，进行真诚的对话——这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实都不太安全，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不。意味着你非得这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑彻底被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这里是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食恶果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听 Love Trapped 播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客节目中，我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和过渡，以及它们意味着什么。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode
对我们的心理。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里，收听新的一期节目。
as we of course break down the very exciting, very unique psychology of our 20s. Before we begin, I wanted to give a quick shout out to my other podcast mantra. You heard that correctly. You may not know,
当然，我们要剖析的是非常激动人心、非常独特的二十岁心理学。在开始之前，我想向我的另一档播客节目 Mantra 表示感谢。你没听错。你可能不知道，
but I have not one, but two podcasts and mantra how I explain it is basically the philosophical spiritual meditative sidekick or sister of the psychology of your 20s every Monday I give you a mantra to guide your week something like I'm a magnetic person I know that love won't pass me I let my work speak louder than my doubt I cultivate peace within a mantra to essentially be your mental anchor for the week ahead. Episodes go for around 30 minutes and they include evidence-backed mental exercises
但我其实不仅有一个，而是有两个播客节目。Mantra，我该怎么解释呢，它基本上是《你二十岁的心理学》的哲学、精神、冥想类密友或姐妹篇。每周一，我都会给你一个咒语来指引你的新一周，比如“我是个有吸引力的人”、“我知道真爱不会与我擦肩而过”、“我用工作来证明自己，而不是被自我怀疑淹没”、“我在内心中培植平静”——这个咒语本质上就是你未来一周的心灵锚点。单集时长大约 30 分钟，其中包含有据可查的精神锻炼方法。
for really powerful mindset shifts, general prompts, and a dive into wisdom from great thinkers, plus just some personal stories that I've never spoken about here, stories of heartbreak, stories of grief, of friendship breakups, of major failures that have really defined me in some ways. So this is my ask of you, If you love the psychology of your 20s, give mantra a listen.
为了实现真正强有力的思维转变、通用提示，以及对伟大思想家智慧的深入探讨，此外还有一些我从未在这里讲过的个人故事——心碎的故事、悲伤的故事、友情破裂的故事、以及在某些方面真正定义了我的重大失败。所以这是我对大家的请求，如果你喜欢《你二十岁的心理学》，请给 Mantra 一次收听的机会。
Just try one episode, see what you think. It's very much a passion project for me right now. So if you have feedback, mantras that you think I should do, if you have a deep thought or a dilemma that has been sitting heavy on your heart, on your soul, I would love to hear it. I'll leave a link in the episode description. But again, thank you so much for giving it a listen. Let's get back to the show and what we're talking about today.
只要听一集，看看你的感受。这对我来说目前非常像是一个充满热忱的项目。所以如果你有反馈，或者觉得我应该分享什么咒语，如果你有什么深沉的想法或一直压在心头、灵魂深处的困惑，我很乐意听听。我会在节目简介中留下链接。但再次感谢大家的聆听。让我们回到节目中，聊聊我们今天的讨论话题。
Today, we're going to talk about music, life's soundtrack, I guess. I was listening to Good Hang with Amy Pola and Rashida Jones the other day, and in their episode, Rashida Jones said something really powerful. She essentially said, music is a way that the universe shows us love. And it really inspired this episode and a bit of an investigation into why music is so transcendent, why it shows up in every single culture, what it does to our brains, what it does to our lives, what it does to our bodies, to our emotions. You might think, you know, what's so psychological about music?
今天我们要聊的是音乐，我猜可以说是生活的主题曲。前几天我在听艾米·波勒和拉什达·琼斯的 Good Hang，在她们那一集里，拉什达·琼斯说了一句非常有力量的话。她大意是说，音乐是宇宙向我们展示爱的一种方式。这真的启发了这一期的节目，也促使我进行了一番探索：为什么音乐具有如此超然的力量，为什么它会出现在每一个单一的文化中，它对我们的大脑、生活、身体和情绪有什么影响。你可能会想，你知道的，音乐有什么好心理学的呢？
You know, what's so important about the songs that I listen to on my morning commute or what plays in the grocery store? I think music feels so ubiquitous and it's everywhere. Sometimes it can just feel like background noise, but it is incredibly psychologically powerful. it is honestly a spiritual experience at times. Music has the ability to connect us, transport us, to shape our emotions, to ignite memories, even to influence our perception of reality. It is actually a fundamental part of our human experience.
你知道的，我在早晨通勤时听的歌，或者杂货店里播放的音乐，有什么重要的呢？我觉得音乐无处不在，而且十分普遍。有时它可能只像是背景噪音，但它在心理上具有令人难以置信的强大力量。老实说，有时它甚至是一种精神体验。音乐有能力将我们连接在一起、带我们去往别处、塑造我们的情绪、点燃记忆，甚至影响我们对现实的感知。它其实是我们人类体验中不可或缺的一部分。
It is a profound psychological force. Some people would even call it the universal language because of how it speaks to our nervous system. So if you've ever had that magical feeling of goosebumps, of suddenly being able to smell the first time you heard a song of being transported back to your first heartbreak of finding that one song can completely change your day, I want to explain that today. We're going to pull apart why music hits us so hard, why we like the music that we do, where your music preference came from. also the neuroscience behind the emotional surges that it creates. I also want to talk about the link between music and memory, between music and personality, between music and intelligence. And I also want to get into how different frequencies, different BPMs, different kinds
它是一种深邃的心理力量。鉴于它如何与我们的神经系统对话，有些人甚至称它为通用语言。所以，如果你曾经有过那种神奇的感觉——起鸡皮疙瘩、突然能闻到第一次听到某首歌时的气味、被带回到第一次心碎的时刻、发现某一首歌可以彻底改变你的一天——我想在今天解释这一切。我们将剖析为什么音乐对我们的冲击如此之大、为什么我们喜欢我们所听的音乐、你的音乐偏好从何而来，以及它所产生的强烈情绪波动背后的神经科学原理。我还想聊聊音乐与记忆之间的联系、音乐与性格的关系、音乐与智力的关系。我还想探讨不同的频率、不同的每分钟节拍数（BPM）、不同种类的。
of music can actually change your thinking style and can actually put you into certain, I guess, I don't want to say like spaces, like mental spaces. certain types of music can actually activate different kinds of brainwaves that will help you when you're studying, that will help you when you're suffering, that will help you when you're running, whatever it is. I want to give you the formula for what music to listen to, when and so much more. I'm so excited for this episode. A little fun fact for you guys. As a child, I actually always thought I was going to be a musician.
音乐实际上可以改变你的思维方式，并真正让你进入某种状态，我猜，我不想说得像什么空间，而是精神空间。某些类型的音乐实际上可以激活不同种类的脑电波，在你学习时帮助你，在你遭受痛苦时帮助你，在你跑步时帮助你，无论你在做什么。我想为你提供一份公式：什么时候该听什么音乐，以及更多精彩内容。我为这一期节目感到非常兴奋。给你们讲个有趣的小八卦。小时候，我其实一直以为自己会成为一名音乐家。
I played trombone. I played piano. I used to write songs. I sang constantly. I came from such a musical family. And so this episode was particularly fascinating to me to be able to investigate a little bit further for you guys. So without further ado, let's tune into the psychology of music. Let's cut straight to the chase.
我吹过长号。我弹过钢琴。我以前写过歌。我不停地唱歌。我来自这样一个充满音乐氛围的家庭。所以这一期节目对我来说特别吸引人，能为你们做进一步的探索。那么闲话少说，让我们调频到音乐的心理学。让我们直奔主题。
What the heck is going on in our heads when we play a certain song when we press play? It is not just sound waves hitting our eardrums. it is a full-on neurological concert, like a symphony of brain activity that is going to explain to us why music feels so freaking vital. So when a melody, when a rhythm, a harmony reaches your brain, it doesn't just stay confined to the parts that process sound. So there's been a whole team of neuroscientists who've been trying to figure out where is music actually processed, including a big team at McGill University and they've shown through fMRI scans that music actually lights up a whole network of brain regions. It lights up the amygdala, our brain's basically emotional powerhouse.
当我们播放某首歌、按下播放键时，我们的脑子里到底在搞什么鬼？这不仅仅是声波撞击我们的耳膜。这是一场全面的神经学音乐会，就像一场大脑活动的交响乐，它将向我们解释为什么音乐会让人感觉如此该死的重要。所以，当旋律、节奏、和声触及你的大脑时，它并不局限于处理声音的区域。有一整支神经科学家团队一直在试图弄清楚音乐到底是在哪里被处理的，其中包括麦吉尔大学的一个大团队，他们通过功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）扫描显示，音乐实际上会点亮整个大脑区域网络。它点亮了杏仁核，也就是我们大脑中的情感引擎。
It lights up the hippocampus, which is critical for memory formation and even areas involved in motor control, which is why you might involuntarily, you know, like start tapping your foot or bobbing your head, even if you're trying to stay still. I think a lot of us have had that experience where we're like, oh my gosh, like we just can't stop moving to a song involuntarily because of how music touches different parts of our brains. Very interestingly, what they found is that this full brain, full mind, full neurological explosion is very similar to when we fall in love. It's very similar to when we experience fear. It's very similar to when we experience deep sadness. So music is infiltrating all of these different emotional cortexes and emotional systems. It also elicits
它点亮了海马体，这对记忆的形成至关重要，甚至还点亮了与运动控制相关的区域，这就是为什么你可能会不由自主地，你知道的，开始用脚打拍子或点头，即使你正努力保持静止。我想我们很多人都有过这种体验，我们会想，哦天哪，由于音乐触及我们大脑的不同部分，我们简直无法控制自己不去随着一首歌扭动。非常有趣的是，他们发现这种全脑、全心、全面的神经学爆发非常类似于当我们坠入爱河时的反应。这与我们经历恐惧时的反应非常相似。这与我们经历深深的悲伤时非常相似。所以音乐正在渗透到所有这些不同的情感皮层和情感系统中。它还能引发。
feelings on its own. It's responsible for creating certain emotional states, you know, happiness, joyfulness, loneliness, calm, pain. How does this happen? A huge part of it comes down to dopamine. You have probably heard of dopamine. Everyone thinks of it as our brains. Reward Chemical. It's the one that's associated with pleasure, motivation. And also what you may not know is it's associated with anticipation. And this is critical.
它自身的情感。它负责创造某些情绪状态，你知道的，快乐、喜悦、孤独、平静、痛苦。这是怎么发生的？其中很大一部分原因归结于多巴胺。你可能听说过多巴胺。每个人都认为它是我们大脑的奖励化学物质。它与快乐、动机有关。你可能还不知道的是，它还与期待有关。这一点至关重要。
So this beautiful author, his name is Daniel Levitin, and he has this book called This Is Your Brain on Music. And he explains how the reason that music makes us feel so good is because it creates anticipation. Think about like a build-up in a dance track or like a gradual crescendo and like a classical musical piece or like a verse leading into a chorus. Your brain almost unconsciously starts predicting what's coming. And that prediction, that like that feeling of waiting,
这位优秀的作家，他的名字叫丹尼尔·列维廷（Daniel Levitin），他写过一本书叫《这就是你的音乐大脑》（This Is Your Brain on Music）。他解释了为什么音乐让我们感觉如此美妙，是因为它创造了期待。想想看，比如舞曲中的蓄势，或者古典音乐作品中渐强的渐高，再或者副歌之前的过渡段。你的大脑几乎在无意识中开始预测接下来会发生什么。而那种预测，那种等待的感觉，
that's where the dopamine really starts flowing. And so when the musical payoff arrives, when you hit the high note, when the chorus drops, when the harmony resolves, like, you get that satisfying hit. So this is the same neural pathway that gets activated when you're waiting for a really delicious meal and you take the first bite, or when you achieve a goal or you even get like a text from someone that you really, really like. Music is tapping into our fundamental reward system, and it's inherently pleasurable because of anticipation. It's not just that pleasure principle even. Music can also profoundly alter your physiological arousal,
这正是多巴胺真正开始分泌的地方。因此，当音乐的高潮到来时，当你唱到高音时，当副歌爆发时，当和声解决时，你会得到那种令人满足的快感。所以，这与当你等待一顿极其美味的饭菜并吃下第一口时，或者当你达成一个目标，甚至收到你非常非常喜欢的人发来的短信时，被激活的是完全相同的神经通路。音乐正在接入我们的基本奖励系统，而且由于期待的存在，它本质上是令人愉悦的。甚至不仅仅是快乐原则。音乐还可以深刻地改变你的生理唤醒水平，
basically how awake, alert, or calm your body feels. And this is thanks to something called entrainment. Entrainment is this phenomenon where your internal biological rhythms, your heart rate, your breathing, even your brain waves, actually synchronize with external, rhythms like those in music. I find it's so fascinating that our bodies can do this. It's like this beautiful piece of evidence to me of the miracle of existence that our brains sink up to rhythm and sync up to song and sound. If you put on a slow, ambient, calm piece of music, your heart rate
基本上就是你的身体感觉有多清醒、警觉或平静。这要归功于一种叫做“共振”（entrainment）的现象。共振是指这样一种现象：你内部的生物节律、心率、呼吸，甚至脑电波，实际上与外部节奏（如音乐中的节奏）同步了。我觉得我们的身体能做到这一点真是太迷人了。在我看来，这是关于生存奇迹的一个美丽的证据，证明了我们的大脑能够与节奏同步，与歌曲和声音同步。如果你播放一首缓慢、舒缓、平静的音乐，你的心率。
will start to subtly decrease. Your breathing starts to deepen. You literally physically relax and sync up to the music. Conversely, if you are listening to like techno or house, your heart rate will pick up. Your breathing becomes quicker and you will feel that surge of energy. That's why when you're running, we really enjoy listening to songs with a higher tempo because it matches the activity that we're doing, making us feel more tuned in. So this isn't just about feeling good. It is actually about music acting as a direct, uncontrised,
就会开始微妙地下降。你的呼吸开始加深。你字面意义上、身体上都放松了下来，并与音乐同步。相反地，如果你在听像电音或浩室舞曲（house），你的心率就会加快。你的呼吸会变得急促，你会感受到一股能量的涌动。这就是为什么当你跑步时，我们真的很喜欢听节奏更快的歌曲，因为它符合我们正在进行的活动，让我们感觉更投入。所以这不仅仅是感觉良好的问题。这实际上关乎音乐充当了一种直接的、非人为干预的调节器。
regulator of your body's internal states. We use this idea, well, our bodies take advantage of entrainment to manage how we feel, often without even realizing that we're doing it. Let's talk about the role of music in significant emotional periods of our lives as well and how it can emotionally regulate us. Particularly, let's focus it on breakups. I feel like music and breakups are symbiotic. Like they feed off each other in a weird way. Every single artist in the history of this planet has had some kind of breakup song or some song that is motivated by heartache because it is music's probably greatest fuel. And then on the flip side, music also tends to make heartbreak feel almost a little bit more bearable in a way. I have a few breakup playlists that I made during past
调节你身体的内部状态。我们利用这个概念，或者说我们的身体利用共振来管理我们的感受，通常甚至没有意识到我们在这样做。让我们也来聊聊音乐在我们生活中重要的情感时期所扮演的角色，以及它如何能在情感上调节我们。特别是，让我们把焦点放在失恋上。我觉得音乐和失恋是共生的。它们以一种奇特的方式相互滋养。这个星球历史上每一位艺术家都有过某种失恋歌曲，或者某种由心碎激发的歌曲，因为这是音乐最伟大的燃料。而另一方面，音乐往往也让心碎在某种程度上变得不那么难以忍受。我在过去的心碎。
heartaches and heartbreaks. And I've I was listening back to them when I was writing this episode and it really transported me back to that time. What I remember is how songs that were intended to feel sad and devastating did make me feel sad and devastated, but they actually also provided me with this really intense catharsis. And I remember listening to this one song in particular. It's called Is It Just Me by Emily Burns? and I was listening to it in my car near the beach, maybe a month after I broke up with my first boyfriend
和失恋时期制作过一些失恋播放列表。当我写这一期节目回听它们时，它真的把我带回了那个时期。我记得的是，那些旨在让人感到悲伤和毁灭性的歌曲确实让我感到悲伤和毁灭性，但它们实际上也给我带来了非常强烈的情感宣泄（catharsis）。我记得特别是在听这样一首歌。它叫《Is It Just Me》，是艾米·伯恩斯（Emily Burns）唱的。我在海滩附近的车里听着这首歌，大概是在我和第一任男友分手一个月后。
and just sobbing and sobbing so much that this older man came over to check that I was okay. And I also remember feeling a lot better afterwards. It like pushed me to a really low point, but then allowed me to dwell in that feeling and then move on. The power of a breakup song is that it provides an opportunity to feel the feeling as deeply as possible, the many feelings as deeply as possible, to get in sync with that feeling, let it wash over you, and then feel it lessen as you get it all out. What is the best breakup song according to psychology? Now, this was something that I really wanted to find out. I couldn't give you a specific answer, but there do seem to be a few critical things that a good breakup song has to contain. The best breakup song has to have a 10.5.5.
哭得稀里哗啦，以至于一个老爷爷走过来查看我是否还好。我还记得之后感觉好多了。它把我推向了一个非常低谷的时刻，但随后允许我在那种感觉中停留，然后继续前行。失恋歌曲的力量在于，它提供了一个机会，去尽可能深地感受那种感觉，尽可能深地去感受多种多样的情绪，与那种情绪同步，让它席卷你，然后随着你把一切都宣泄出来，那种感觉逐渐减轻。根据心理学的研究，最好的失恋歌曲是什么？现在，这是我真的很想找出的答案。我无法给你一个具体的答案，但一首好的失恋歌曲似乎确实包含几个至关重要的要素。最好的失恋歌曲必须有一个 10.5.5。
and release, something that builds up and builds up and builds up to like an explosion point and then goes down. B, it has to have emotional vulnerability of some sort. C, relatability and specificity. So the more detail, the better. Think about like Taylor Swift's classic breakup song all too well. There's so much detail in that that feels specific but is actually quite general so people can relate to it. They see themselves in those feelings. in those circumstances that transported to that time. Indeed, it has to have a hook, a really good line, a really good harmony that you can kind of croon over again and again and again, all of which provides the emotional catharsis and the closure
和释放，也就是不断积蓄、积蓄、再积蓄，直到达到一个爆发点，然后下落。B，它必须具有某种情感上的脆弱性。C，共鸣和具体性。所以细节越多越好。想想泰勒·斯威夫特的经典失恋歌曲《All Too Well》。里面有那么多细节，感觉很具体，但实际上又相当普遍，所以人们能与之产生共鸣。他们在那些感受中看到了自己。在那些场景中被带回到那个时代。确实，它必须有一个主旋律（hook），一句非常好的歌词，一段非常棒的和声，你可以一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地轻轻哼唱，所有这些都提供了情感宣泄和释怀。
almost, even if it's just in that moment that our heart really, really wants. According to a 2014 study, break up music, sad music, is more about nostalgia. It's more about reminiscing that it is actually about grief or sadness, which actually means that listening to sad music makes it almost a positive experience. So the other thing that break up songs really do is that they kind of transport us through time. They unlock, they resurrect memories, they let us relive memories that maybe we've forgotten. Music in general has this amazing capability. You know, you're living your life, you're just going along and then suddenly,
几乎，即使只是在我们内心非常非常渴望的那一瞬间。根据 2014 年的一项研究，失恋音乐、伤感音乐更多的是关于怀旧。它更多的是关于追忆，而不是真正的悲伤或痛苦，这意味着听伤感音乐几乎成了一种积极的体验。所以失恋歌曲真正做到的另一件事是，它们在某种程度上带我们穿越了时间。它们解锁、复活了记忆，让我们重温那些可能已经被遗忘了的记忆。音乐通常具有这种神奇的功能。你知道的，你过着你的生活，一切如常，突然之间，
you'll hear a song from when you were a kid or from some significant period and you are like immediately transferred back there. And it's not just that your memories are being played in your head. It's almost a sensory experience. You can smell your childhood home. You can feel the tension and the energy between you and that situation ship. You feel that distinct bittersweet ache. You can taste certain things. It is a full body time machine for your brain. So why is music so intrinsically linked to memory? So psychologists who study autobiographical memory, so that's basically memory that contains your personal history, your lived experiences, they have a few powerful theories. First, music is often deeply intertwined with highly emotional events. Our brains,
你会听到一首你小时候或某个重要时期的歌，然后你就立刻被传送回了那里。这不仅仅是你的记忆在脑海中播放。这几乎是一种感官体验。你能闻到童年房子的味道。你能感受到你和那个暧昧对象之间的紧张感和能量。你能感受到那种独特的苦乐参半的痛楚。你能尝到某些东西。对你的大脑来说，这是一个全身心的时光机。那么，为什么音乐与记忆会有如此内在的联系呢？研究自传体记忆（也就是包含你个人历史、生活经历的记忆）的心理学家们有几个强有力的理论。首先，音乐往往与高度情绪化的事件深度交织在一起。我们的大脑，
particularly the hippocampus, which is the memory formation center and the amygdala, they work hand in hand to code what they see as significant experiences. So the more intense an emotion or experiences is at the time, the more information is taken in from the environment to ensure that that memory is really locked into our brain. If a memory, if a moment is highly emotionally salient, basically our brain is like this is something we want to be able to reflect on because it may be able to help us in future experiences something this intense is something that we can't forget so
特别是海马体（即记忆形成中心）和杏仁核，它们携手合作，为它们视为重大经验的东西进行编码。因此，当时的某种情绪或经历越强烈，从环境中获取的信息就越多，以确保该记忆真正锁定在我们的大脑中。如果一段记忆、一个时刻在情感上高度显著，基本上我们的大脑就会认为这是我们想要反思的东西，因为它可能对我们未来的经历有所帮助，如此强烈的事情是我们不能忘记的，所以。
instead of just remembering one element of the scene or one element of the event it will start to code the smells the sounds the feelings the taste the lightness the brightness all of those things and so music becomes attached to these really hard moments when you hear that song again you're not just retrieving the musical information, all the other rich emotional sensory details that were encoded with it will come along. It's a phenomenon known as the Proust effect, actually, whereby a sensory experience brings up intense memories it was initially tied to. And music is one of those powerful sensory experiences.
它不会只记住场景的一个要素或事件的一个要素，而是开始对气味、声音、感觉、味道、光线、亮度以及所有这些东西进行编码。因此，当音乐与这些艰难的时刻联系在一起时，当你再次听到这首歌时，你不仅是在检索音乐信息，所有与之编码在一起的丰富的情感感官细节也会随之涌现。这其实是一种被称为“普鲁斯特效应”（Proust effect）的现象，即感官体验会唤起它最初与之绑定的强烈记忆。而音乐就是那些强大的感官体验之一。
Secondly, music is often tied and associated with specific context, specifically because songs tend to be played and repeated for short periods of time, if that makes sense. So hit songs will play for a summer over the radio, meaning that, and then you might not hear it for a while, meaning that it really is stuck to that moment. Or a certain playlist or song that you really like is something that you're going to play over and over and over again. So it becomes associated with the time and also with the feeling of that time. So whether it's an album, whether it's a playlist, whether it is a hit song, this all creates a really strong context-dependent memory.
其次，音乐通常与特定的语境绑定并相关联，这主要是因为歌曲往往会在短时间内被播放和重复，如果可以这样理解的话。因此，热门歌曲会在夏天通过广播一遍又遍地播放，这意味着，随后你可能有一段时间听不到它，这意味着它真的深深烙印在了那个时刻。或者你非常喜欢某个播放列表或某首歌，你会一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地播放它。因此，它与那个时间以及那个时期的感觉联系在了一起。所以无论是专辑、播放列表还是热门歌曲，这一切都创造了一种非常强烈的与语境相关的记忆。
The music becomes the environmental cue. So when you re-encounter that cue, your brain has a direct pathway back to that specific time and place. It's like musical time travel. What's even more fascinating is actually how resilient yours and I's musical memory can be. researchers who are currently working with individuals who have severe memory impairments. So they've had brain damage, they have dementia. They often find that musical memories are among the last memories to fade. Isn't that just like wonderful?
音乐成为了环境线索。因此，当你再次遇到这个线索时，你的大脑就拥有了一条直通那个特定时间和地点的通路。这就像是音乐时光旅行。更令人着迷的是你我的音乐记忆究竟能有多强韧。研究人员目前正在与患有严重记忆受损的个体合作。例如他们受过脑损伤，患有痴呆症。他们经常发现，音乐记忆是最后消逝的记忆之一。这难道不是很奇妙吗？
Obviously not the memory loss part, but wow. Like I find that really special to think that the songs that I'm listening to now well, might be one of the last things that I remember if I go through memory loss. People can struggle to recall their own names. They don't know what their children's names are, but they can sing along to songs from their childhood. They can even learn new harmonies. They can tune into new songs.
当然不是指失忆的部分，但是哇。我觉得这真的很特别，想到我现在听的歌，如果我以后经历记忆丧失，这可能是我最后记住的事情之一。人们可能会挣扎着回忆起自己的名字。他们不知道自己孩子的名字，但他们能跟着童年的歌曲一起唱歌。他们甚至能学会新的和声。他们可以调频到新的歌曲。
And this really suggests that musical memories are processed and stored in slightly different, perhaps more distributed brain regions, meaning that's, they're very, very robust. So whilst people are still trying to figure out where exactly certain memories are stored, what they do know is that certain memories are stored in different places, because they'll find that certain types of memories will fade almost all at the same time. And so what this is saying is that music is stored in so many different places that even as all these structures of the brain deteriorate, it remains.
这确实表明，音乐记忆是在略有不同、也许更分散的大脑区域中被处理和储存的，这意味着它们非常非常坚固。因此，虽然人们仍在试图弄清楚某些记忆究竟储存在哪里，但他们所知道的是，某些记忆储存在不同的地方，因为他们会发现某种类型的记忆几乎会同时消逝。所以这就说明，音乐被储存在如此之多的不同地方，以至于即使大脑的所有这些结构都在退化，它依然存在。
So I just think it's such a testament to how vital music is for our for life. Like, I know I'm sounding very dramatic here, but it is life-giving. It is memory-given. Like, it is, it makes us so human and connected. There is a slight problem with that, though.
所以我认为这绝对是对音乐对生命而言有多么重要的一种证明。好吧，我知道我在这里听起来很戏剧化，但它确实赋予生命活力。它赋予记忆活力。它让我们如此具有人性且彼此相连。不过，这也有一个小问题。
The fact that music can transport us so powerfully means that sometimes it can also be a source of deep pain, of deep nostalgia, and it can be kind of like a self-punishing, tool where we listen to songs that we know are going to make us feel terrible time and time again as a way to pull us back into that time rather than move forward. It means that a lot of music from your past can sometimes bring up emotions and feelings that are less resolved than they should be. Like they're just, they're still buzzing in the background and you haven't had a chance to
音乐能以如此强大的力量带我们回到过去，这也意味着有时它也可能成为痛苦之源、深深的怀旧之源，它可能有点像一种自我惩罚的工具，我们一遍又一遍地听那些明知会让自己感觉糟糕透顶的歌，以此来把自己拉回那个时期，而不是向前看。这意味着你过去的很多音乐有时会唤起那些本该得到解决却尚未解决的情绪和感觉。就像它们只是在背景中嗡嗡作响，而你没有机会去。
address them, but you're using music as a way to stay tuned into that time. So, whilst it is a really powerful magical bridge, it's also worth noting whether music is allowing you to pity yourself and to linger and to stay stuck in a period of time or whether it is just a nice place to visit. If you're constantly listening to music that is making it hard from you to move on from a chapter in your life, perhaps it's becoming a bit of a problem in some ways. I will say, I do think that music is also really beautiful in that way, in that it gives you a marker for how much you've grown. So I was telling you guys that I was listening to some of these breakup playlist
解决它们，但你却把音乐当作保持与那个时期同频的一种方式。所以，虽然它是一座非常强大、神奇的桥梁，但也值得注意的是，音乐是让你顾影自怜、徘徊不前并困在某一个时期，还是仅仅成为了一个适合游览的好去处。如果你一直在听那些让你难以走出人生某一章节的音乐，也许它在某些方面已经变成了一个小问题。不过我要说的是，我确实认为音乐在这一点上也非常美丽，它为你提供了一个衡量你成长了多少的标志。所以我之前告诉过你们，我正在听我生命中重大失恋时期的一些失恋播放列表。
that I used to have from significant breakups in my life. And the interesting thing was listening back to them. I used to obviously listen to them to bring up painful feelings and to hopefully resolve them. And now, when I listen to them, I feel really bittersweet. I feel it's not happiness, it's just like comfort almost. I listen to them and I feel like I'm giving the past version of me like a really big warm hug because I knew how much those songs affected her at the time and they just no longer do.
有趣的是回听它们。我以前显然是为了唤起痛苦的感受并希望能解决它们而听。而现在，当我听它们时，我感到一种苦乐参半。这不是快乐，几乎只是一种安慰。我听着它们，感觉自己好像在给过去的那个自己一个非常大、非常温暖的拥抱，因为我知道当时那些歌对她的影响有多大，而现在它们再也不会了。
So it is like a really beautiful way to see how far you've grown. Okay, we're going to take a short break, but when we return, I want to tell you what music has to say about your personality. specifically how your music preference is formed, what it might say about you, but also how to really utilize the incredible psychological power of music to elevate your life, elevate your work, elevate your concentration. So stick around and stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
所以这真是一个美丽的方式，让你看到自己已经成长了多少。好了，我们要休会片刻，但等我们回来时，我想告诉你音乐对你的性格有什么启示。特别是你的音乐偏好是如何形成的，它可能说明了你是个什么样的人，以及如何真正利用音乐那令人难以置信的心理力量来提升你的生活、提升你的工作、提升你的注意力。所以请不要走开，继续收听。《百分之二》。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《百分之二》中。我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上对之感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力造成的。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side. a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨。成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《百分之二》。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上搜索 T-W-O-Persent 收听。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，绝对不要去惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会获得愚蠢的奖品。
And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands.
规则二，也绝对不要去惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女友们》的这一新季中，“天哪，这是同一个人。”一群女性发现她们竟然都在和同一个多产的职业骗子约会。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一下。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定自己采取行动。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed, I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓，我要成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMAs 上双击（double-tap）莉儿·金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉儿·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在 Look Back at it 播客节目中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请了马可·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目。
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
大谈 80 年代的快克（crack）。坦白说，1984 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备一整天都在聊快克，不过只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马可，到了这个时候，这是我们第二集讨论快克了，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在还有艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以……谢谢你把这句话说完。是的，我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years. for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听 Look Back at It。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough
为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某样东西的过程中，我们过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了这样东西，却依然在追逐它，而且我们不知道什么时候才算够。
because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app, search Learn the Hardway and listen now. Music, obviously, has many, many functions, but it can actually be a tool to really discover your personality. And that might sound bizarre, but the research on the links between personality and music taste is incredibly expansive and honestly.
因为人们把生活当成了记分牌，生活变成了输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个好人很重要，无论你是在地球上活着，还是你成为一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟，绝对是的，那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人，加入我——基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App，搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。音乐显然有很多很多的功用，但它实际上也可以成为一个真正发现你性格的工具。这听起来可能很离奇，但关于性格与音乐品味之间联系的研究极其广泛，而且老实说。
so spot on at times. I'm going to talk about the findings from a few studies here to give you an oversight about what kind of music says what about what kind of person. So the first study that I want to talk about is this one from 2014. And this study looked at 772 participants and found that people who enjoy sad music have greater empathy, but also greater emotional sensitivity. Hence why they get so much pleasure from really sinking into a song that is quite vulnerable
有时非常精准。我将在这里谈论几项研究的发现，让你对什么样的音乐说明了什么样的人有一个总体了解。我想谈的第一项研究是 2014 年的这一项。该研究调查了 772 名参与者，发现喜欢伤感音乐的人具有更强的同理心，但同时也具有更高的情绪敏感性。因此，难怪他们能从真正沉浸在一首相当脆弱。
and intense. So if you find that the majority of your playlists are quite sad and forlorn and, you know, low, dark, moody, it might be that actually you're going to perform higher on tests of empathy and of emotional sensitivity. A second study using Spotify listening history, which I think is such a great database if you obviously give them permission to use it. The study was published in 2020 and it had a 44 item questionnaire for personality and then it also compared and matched those personality scores with what people were listening to and it found over 50 correlations between how many playlists you had, your favorite artist, your genre of choice and all these things and what kind of person that you may be. For example, they found that people who listen to more folk music are more open to new experiences.
且激烈的歌曲中获得如此多的快感。所以，如果你发现你的大部分播放列表都相当伤感、凄凉，而且你知道的，低沉、黑暗、忧郁，那可能是因为你在同理心和情绪敏感性测试中的得分会更高。第二项研究利用了 Spotify 的收听历史，如果你显然授权他们使用的话，我认为这是一个非常棒的数据库。该研究于 2020 年发表，包含了一份针对性格的 44 项调查问卷，然后它将这些性格得分与人们正在听的音乐进行了比较和匹配，结果发现在你有多少个播放列表、你最喜欢的艺术家、你的首选流派以及所有这些因素与你可能是个什么样的人之间，存在 50 多种相关性。例如，他们发现听民谣（folk）音乐较多的人对新体验更加开放。
They're also more open to new experiences, the more artists they follow. So if someone's following more artists, the more likely they're going to want to travel and they're going to want to see. things and taste new foods. People who were high in conscientiousness were less likely to listen to things like emo and punk and they were more likely to listen to soul and country and not just country, old country. The most extroverted people in this study tended to listen more to other people's playlists and they listened to R&B, Caribbean, funk and country the most. It's just so fascinating, much this has to tell us about ourselves. I would really recommend checking out all these results as a study that I think Spotify actually did or they lent their data to. If you just look up
他们关注的艺术家越多，对新体验的开放度也越高。因此，如果一个人关注的艺术家越多，他们就越有可能想要去旅行，想要去看。各种事物并品尝新的食物。在尽责性（conscientiousness）得分高的人不太可能听诸如情绪摇滚（emo）和朋克之类的音乐，他们更有可能听灵歌（soul）和乡村音乐，而且不仅仅是乡村音乐，是老乡村音乐。这项研究中最外向的人往往听别人播放列表的频率更高，他们听 R&B、加勒比音乐、放克（funk）和乡村音乐最多。这真是太迷人了，这些对我们自身有这么多的揭示。我强烈建议大家去查阅所有这些结果，这是一项我认为 Spotify 实际上做过或者他们借出了数据的研究。如果你去查。
Spotify, music, personality score, whatever it is, I'm sure you'll find it. Finally, another really fun factor around the link between personality and music that I found was from a worldwide 2015 study that found that people who empathize more with other people's emotions tend to prefer genres like soft rock, R&B, and folk, but people who are more logical, what we call systemizers, prefer heavy metal, classical and complex music. It also turns out that we generally actually form our music taste between the ages of 13 and 16. The music that we listen to and that we like during that period tends to stick with us for a very, very, very long time. I think when you find an artist who really, or a genre that really articulates how you feel during those formative years, during your teen years and that perfectly captures your internal turmoil and your joy, it is very, very validating.
Spotify、音乐、性格得分，无论怎么搜，我相信你都能找到。最后，关于性格与音乐之间联系的另一个非常有趣的因素，我发现来自一项 2015 年的全球研究，该研究发现，更能对他人情绪产生同理心的人倾向于喜欢轻摇滚、R&B 和民谣等流派，而更具逻辑性的人（我们称之为系统化者）则更喜欢重金属、古典音乐和复杂的音乐。事实证明，我们通常实际上是在 13 到 16 岁之间形成我们的音乐品味的。我们在那个时期听的、喜欢的音乐往往会伴随我们非常、非常、非常长的时间。我想，当你找到一个真正能够表达你在那些成型期、在你的青少年时期你的感受的艺术家或流派，并且它完美地捕捉到了你内心的动荡和喜悦时，这会是非常、非常有认同感的。
It's like being able to feel like there's someone else in this world who gets you and someone gets it and you're not alone. And that act of recognition, that feeling of being understood through art is fundamental to solidify. what you tell yourself about yourself. It tells you in a way, music is able to confirm to you, this is who I am, this is what resonates with me, these are the kind of people that I'm like. Beyond individual expression, I think also music is a really beautiful way to make friends. It's incredibly socially connective. It's such a powerful engine for group affiliation. We all know this feeling intuitively, right? You know, you meet someone new, One of the things you may talk about is what kind of music you like.
这就好像能感觉到，在这个世界上有另一个人懂你，有人理解你，你并不孤单。而这种被认可的行为，这种通过艺术被理解的感觉，对于巩固你对自己的认知至关重要。它在某种程度上告诉你，音乐能够向你确认：这就是我，这就是与我共鸣的事物，这些就是和我一类的人。除了个人表达之外，我认为音乐也是交朋友的一种非常美妙的方式。它具有极强的社交连接性。它是群体归属感的强大引擎。我们凭直觉都知道这种感觉，对吧？比如，你结识了一个新朋友，你们可能会聊的话题之一就是你喜欢什么类型的音乐。
And if there is a shared love there, boom, it's like an instant connection. If someone likes the same artists and the same music, you almost assume that they're a very similar person to you on factors that go a lot deeper than musical preference. So this really taps into something called social identity theory. Core concept in social psychology, it suggests that a significant part of our self-concept comes from the groups we belong to. and we are constantly trying to find our way or a way to connect to those groups. Liking the same music doesn't feel superficial.
如果你们有共同的爱好，轰的一下，就像瞬间来电一样。如果有人喜欢同样的歌手和同样的音乐，你甚至会认为他们在比音乐偏好更深层的因素上，与你是一个非常相似的人。所以这实际上触及了被称为“社会认同理论”的概念。这是社会心理学的一个核心概念，它表明我们的自我概念很大一部分来自于我们所属的群体，而且我们一直在努力寻找自己的方向，或者寻找一种与这些群体建立联系的方式。喜欢同样的音乐并不显得肤浅。
It often signals shared values, similar cultural experiences, even common emotional landscapes, similar chapters and periods of your life. I always think about going to a Taylor Swift concert, going to the Eros Tour last year and looking around and being like, oh yeah, I could probably be friends with every single person here, not because we might have a lot in common, but because I know that we definitely have a few things shared if we've been able to resonate with this music. Concerts as well are just like, if music brings us happiness and joy and pleasure, concerts like dial that up by a thousand, a million, a billion. The shared energy,
它通常标志着共同的价值观、相似的文化经历，甚至是共同的情感风景、相似的人生章节和时期。我总是想起去听泰勒·斯威夫特的演唱会，去年去看Eras巡回演唱会时环顾四周，心想，哦，是的，我大概能和这里的每一个人成为朋友，不是因为我们可能有很多共同点，而是因为我知道，如果我们能对这种音乐产生共鸣，我们肯定有一些共同之处。演唱会也同样如此，如果音乐给我们带来幸福、快乐和愉悦，演唱会就像是将这种感觉放大了一千倍、一百万倍、十亿倍。那种共同的能量，
singing along, the feeling of unity in a crowd of thousands. that is a very powerful psychological phenomenon. It's why people scream and cry and go crazy at concerts and festivals. It's this release of oxytocin, the bonding hormone that is being shared and creating this synchronized experience. It's a sense of belonging. It's a sense of being part of something bigger than you, which we all want to be part of. And in our 20s in particular, in our teens, like loneliness is such a silent struggle
跟着一起唱，在成千上万的人群中感受到的团结，这是一种非常强大的心理现象。这就是为什么人们在演唱会和音乐节上会尖叫、哭泣和疯狂。这是催产素的释放，这种被称为“社交激素”的东西在人群中共享，并创造了这种同步的体验。这是一种归属感。这是一种成为比自己更伟大的事物一部分的感觉，而这正是我们所有人都想成为的一部分。特别是在我们的二十几岁，在我们的青少年时期，那种孤独感是无声的挣扎，
during that time, being able to find your musical tribe feels like a lifeline. It's a shorthand to connection. It's a way to build community. You know, I think about all my friends who have these internet friends from when they were on Tumblr and like listening to one direction or like five seconds of summer. It just creates such a unique, connective experience. Here's a subtle but important nuance as well. The music we listen to doesn't just reflect who we are. It also shapes who we are becoming. If you consistently listen to empowering, confident music, it can actually subtly influence your self-perception and your behavior thanks to this concept called effective priming. Exposure to certain stimuli like music can influence our
在那段时间里，能够找到你的音乐同好感觉就像是一根救命稻草。这是连接的捷径。这是建立社群的一种方式。你知道，我想起我所有的那些朋友，他们有来自Tumblr时期的网络好友，当时他们听单向乐队（One Direction）或者5 Seconds of Summer。这创造了一种非常独特的、具有连接性的体验。这里还有一个微妙但重要的细微差别。我们听的音乐不仅反映了我们是谁，它还在塑造我们正在成为什么样的人。如果你持续听那些赋能的、自信的音乐，由于一个被称为“情感启动”的概念，它实际上可以潜移默化地影响你的自我认知和行为。接触特定刺激（如音乐）会影响我们的
subsequent thoughts and actions. In fact, in a 23 study from the University of Notre Dame, they found that listening to upbeat, happy music for a certain amount of time every day can actually shift your mood. It made people more optimistic and it actually increased how many positive thoughts they were having every single day. Similarly, if you are constantly immersed in music that is angry or melancholic, it can in some states in some ways reinforce those emotions and reinforce that feeling. It shapes your outlook. You, music and you have a very complex relationship. Like, hopefully that's coming through how I'm explaining this. Like, it's this dynamic reciprocal relationship.
随后的思想和行动。事实上，在圣母大学2023年的一项研究中，他们发现每天听一定时间的欢快、愉悦的音乐实际上可以改变你的情绪。它让人变得更乐观，并且确实增加了他们每天产生的积极想法的数量。同样地，如果你一直沉浸在愤怒或忧郁的音乐中，它在某些情况下、在某种程度上会强化这些情绪并加剧那种感觉。它塑造了你的世界观。你、音乐以及你与音乐的关系非常复杂。希望我这样解释能让你明白这一点。这是一种动态的、双向的关系。
I guess, you know, it's similar to repeating mantras. It's similar to words of affirmation. If you are screaming at the top of your lungs that you are incredible, you're going to feel fucking incredible. If you're listening to sad songs that talk about how terrible life is, you're going to feel like life is terrible. So music isn't just a backdrop. It is an active participant in how we see ourselves and how we see the world.
我想，你知道的，这类似于重复诵读咒语。这类似于肯定语。如果你声嘶力竭地大喊你很了不起，你就会觉得自己他妈的了不起。如果你听那些讲述生活有多么糟糕的悲伤歌曲，你就会觉得生活真的很糟糕。所以音乐不仅仅是一个背景。它是我们如何看待自己以及如何看待世界的积极参与者。
So I want to talk about how music functions as a coping mechanism, because for many of us, especially in our 20s, music isn't just about enjoyment. It is a very vital tool for navigating life's ups and downs, the moment of overwhelm at work, the surge of anxiety before a meeting, the feeling of loneliness. Music can shift those feelings. It is an act of emotional regulation. Interestingly, it's not just calming music, ambient music, low-fi music that can do this.
所以我想谈谈音乐是如何作为一种应对机制发挥作用的，因为对于我们许多人来说，尤其是在二十几岁的时候，音乐不仅仅是为了享受。它是应对生活起伏的重要工具，比如工作中的不知所措，开会前的焦虑涌上心头，孤独感。音乐可以改变这些情绪。这是一种情绪调节的行为。有趣的是，不仅是舒缓的音乐、氛围音乐（ambient music）和低保真音乐（lo-fi music）能做到这一点。
The same thing occurs for familiar songs. Songs that we know are comforting because they are predictable and the emotions they elicit have been ones that we've encountered before and we've managed. It's why listening to music from your childhood, listening to like early 2000s pop music, listening to like old Taylor Swift albums or old albums that you loved makes you feel at home in a weird way makes you just feel so comforted. It's like this is a place that I've been before. This is a soundtrack that I'm familiar with. People have obviously started to recognize this. I think Western medicine has started to recognize this. A lot of cultures have understood this
熟悉的歌曲也会产生同样的效果。我们知道的歌曲能带来慰藉，因为它们是可以预测的，并且它们所唤起的情感是我们以前遇到过并已经应付过去的。这就是为什么听童年时期的音乐、听2000年代初的流行音乐、听泰勒·斯威夫特的旧专辑或者你曾经喜爱的旧专辑，会让你有一种奇怪的宾至如归的感觉，让你感到无比宽慰。这就像是：这是我曾经去过的地方。这是我熟悉的配乐。人们显然已经开始认识到这一点。我认为西方医学已经开始认识到这一点。许多文化在过去的
for many, many, many, many decades. We're just kind of catching up as we are with many, many things. Clinical musical therapy is now becoming a much more prevalent therapy. It's a recognized field that uses these very principles that we have been discussing, these neurological principles of music's psychological effects to help people manage anxiety, to help them reduce pain, to help them cope with trauma. Researchers have really demonstrated time and time again how structured musical interventions can lead to significant improvements in emotional well-being.
很多很多很多很多十年里就已经理解了这一点。我们只是在迎头赶上，就像我们在许多许多事情上所做的那样。临床音乐疗法现在正成为一种更加普遍的疗法。这是一个公认的领域，它利用我们一直在讨论的这些原则——音乐心理影响的神经学原理——来帮助人们管理焦虑，帮助他们减轻痛苦，帮助他们应对创伤。研究人员一次又一次地证明了结构化的音乐干预如何能够显著改善情绪健康。
And beyond pure stress relief, making music, making sound, creating things, can also be a fantastic distraction. And it can also be an incredible way to unlock creativity. And we know creativity being frequently creative, links to higher life satisfaction, links to greater well-being, even increases immune response and increases, senses of a sense of emotional safety. I think we're going to see offerings of music therapy, obviously in conjunction with other therapy as well, like CBT or DBT, really increase. Because we're starting to realize that only treating things in a very clinical way, in a very
除了纯粹的缓解压力之外，创作音乐、发出声音、创造事物，也可以是一种极好的消遣。它还可以成为释放创造力的绝佳方式。我们知道，创造力、经常具有创造力与更高的生活满意度息息相关，与更高的幸福感息息相关，甚至能增强免疫反应和安全感。我认为我们将会看到音乐疗法的提供显著增加，当然这也会与其他疗法（如CBT或DBT）结合使用。因为我们开始意识到，仅仅以一种非常临床的、高度
structured way that has to do with you and another person interacting and solving things and thinking about things doesn't always work for people. And finding, like, music. is like this key that unlocks a whole new dimensions of someone's ability to cope and of their memories and of their trauma and their personhood, that it's crazy that we aren't using it more. It's crazy that, you know,
结构化的方式来处理问题——这与你和另一个人互动、解决问题以及思考事情有关——并不总是对每个人都有效。而寻找像音乐这样的东西，就像是一把钥匙，能打开一个人应对能力、记忆、创伤和个性的全新维度，我们居然没有更多地使用它，这太疯狂了。你知道的，
Western medicine has only just woken up to how powerful it can be. Let's talk about another element of this, though, because music can be therapeutic, it can be a distraction, it can be emotionally powerful, it can be a memory jogger. Is there a point where we listen?
西方医学直到现在才意识到它能有多么强大，这太疯狂了。不过，让我们来谈谈它的另一个元素，因为音乐可以具有治疗作用，它可以是一种分心的方式，它可以具有强烈的情感冲击力，它可以是一个记忆唤醒器。我们听音乐有没有一个度？
to too much music. Is there a value in music? Does the value of music diminish beyond a certain point? Yes. Music is an incredible mental distraction to aversive stimuli like pain or boredom. And whilst distraction is a valid, sometimes healthy coping strategy, there is a fine line between distraction and avoidance. Is silence really all that terrible?
听太多音乐有意义吗？超越了一定程度后，音乐的价值会递减吗？是的。音乐对于痛感或无聊等厌恶性刺激来说，是一种极好的精神转移方式。虽然分心是一种有效且有时健康的应对策略，但在分心和逃避之间有一条微妙的界限。沉默真的有那么糟糕吗？
Is it really that bad for you? I was on a run with my friend the other day and we have a running group where we live. Never thought I would be someone who's in a running group, but that's for another time. Anyways, we were like preparing to run and I looked over at her and she didn't have her headphones in and I was like, okay, well, wait, you have your headphones in. And then she was like, oh, no, I'm not going to wear them. And I was like, oh, did you forget them? Like, you can borrow mine.
对你真的有那么坏吗？前几天我和朋友去跑步，我们当地有一个跑步俱乐部。从来没想过自己会加入跑步俱乐部，但那是另一回事了。总之，我们当时正准备跑步，我转头看她，发现她没有戴耳机，于是我说：“哦，等等，你没戴耳机。”然后她说：“哦，不，我不打算戴。”我说：“哦，你忘了吗？你可以借我的。”
And she was like, oh, no. no, like I haven't, my mom has been talking to me about, and I've been reading about how when we constantly have music on or we have sounds distracting us, it can actually pull us away from the present. It can even make us irritated. It can actually make it harder for us to focus. So she did this whole, however many kilometer run with nothing in her ears. And I was like, that is, I could not do that. But it really got me thinking, like, can we listen to too much music? One researcher did say that no more than eight hours a day is best because at that point you can actually start to damage certain auditory systems but also you essentially blunt the emotional effect of music
然后她说：“哦，没有，没有，我妈妈一直在跟我说，而且我也读到过，当我们一直放着音乐或者有声音分散我们注意力时，它实际上会把我们从当下拉开。它甚至会让我们烦躁。它实际上会让我们更难集中注意力。”所以她就这样进行了不知多少公里的跑步，耳朵里什么也没塞。我想，这真是……我可做不到。但这确实让我思考：我们是不是听了太多音乐？一位研究人员确实说过，一天不超过八个小时是最好的，因为到了那个时候，你实际上开始损害某些听觉系统，而且你本质上会削弱音乐
on your mood and motivation like you become less sensitized to it there is value in actually being present in the moment and listening to the natural sounds around you tapping into your senses listening to your surroundings and then using music when you really need it rather than just to something that is always playing in the background. You know, as incredible and invaluable as music is, sometimes it actually gets in the way of being truly where your feet are. I guess it relates to an episode I did on maladaptive daydreaming, right? Daydreaming is beautiful, it's fun, it's magical. If we're constantly doing it, if we're constantly trying to escape the present to be in some kind of fantasy, then it can actually become very unhelpful. Think about this for a second.
对你的情绪和动机的情感影响，就像你对它的敏感度降低了一样。真正活在当下并聆听周围的自然声音、感受你的感官、倾听你的周围环境，然后在真正需要的时候使用音乐，而不是让它一直作为背景音乐播放，这本身是有价值的。你知道，尽管音乐是如此不可思议且无价，但有时它实际上阻碍了你真正做到“脚踏实地”。我想这与我做过的一期关于适应不良性白日梦的播客有关，对吧？白日梦是美好的、有趣的、神奇的。如果我们不断地这样做，如果我们不断地试图逃离当下而去沉浸在某种幻想中，那么它实际上就会变得非常无用。花一秒钟想想这个。
Are you using music to process your sadness? or are you using it to numb you off or distract you? The difference can be subtle, but it's very crucial. Some studies suggest that, yes, listening to sad music can help explore melancholy. Constantly listening to sad music can induce really heavy rumination. It actually might make you feel worse than you would be without it. It's worth considering. So the big question that we have and that I think we've been kind of coming to is,
你是用音乐来处理悲伤？还是用它来麻痹自己或转移注意力？两者的区别可能很微妙，但至关重要。一些研究表明，是的，听悲伤的音乐可以帮助探索忧郁。但如果不断地听悲伤的音乐，则会引发非常沉重的反刍思维。它实际上可能会让你感觉比不听时还要糟糕。这值得深思。所以我们面临的重大问题，也是我认为我们一直在探讨的问题，
is if music is this incredible tool, how do we use it for good? How do we use it to elevate our life, to boost our mood, to make us more focus, make us more creative? The key, I believe, is intentionality. Instead of just letting music happen to you, try and engage with it consciously. Ask yourself, what music makes me feel what and when can I use it intentionally for those moments. So let me explain this a little bit further. One study found that different kinds of music are best for different moments in your life and different kinds of work that you need to do.
那就是：如果音乐是如此不可思议的工具，我们该如何善用它？我们如何利用它来提升生活、振奋情绪、让我们更专注、更具创造力？我认为关键在于“刻意性”。不要只是让音乐被动地灌输给你，试着有意识地与它互动。问问自己：什么音乐在什么时候能让我产生什么感觉，我该如何在这些时刻有意识地使用它。所以让我进一步解释这一点。一项研究发现，不同类型的音乐最适合你生活中的不同时刻，以及你需要完成的不同类型的工作。
So slow instrumental music is best for deep work. It's less likely to interfere with your reading comprehension. It's less likely to interrupt problem solving. It's best to do hard, deep work when you are listening to slow instrumental music. soft, fast music has a positive impact on learning. So when you're engaging in something new, having music that is a little bit more upbeat, maybe has a few lyrics, is better.
因此，慢节奏的纯音乐最适合深度工作。它不太可能干扰你的阅读理解。它不太可能打断问题解决。当你听慢节奏的纯音乐时，最适合进行艰巨、深度的脑力劳动。轻柔、快节奏的音乐对学习有积极的影响。所以当你接触新事物时，听一点更欢快、也许带几句歌词的音乐会更好。
Very upbeat music with a higher tempo helps you when you're doing something that requires movement or motivation, like you're exercising, you're cleaning your room. But in a very difficult task, when you're doing a very difficult task, you're memorizing material, you are problem solving, like doing in-depth, problem-solving, maybe like advanced calculus, I don't know, the more likely music is actually distancing and distracting you, and that's when you need to turn it off. So I actually think it's important to curate your own playlist for different contexts. Instead of just having a random collection
节奏感很强的欢快音乐可以帮助你进行需要运动或动力的活动，比如你在锻炼、打扫房间。但在非常困难的任务中——当你正在做一项非常困难的任务、在背诵材料、在解决问题时，比如进行深入的问题解决、也许像高等微积分（我不知道）——音乐越是有可能让你分心和走神，而这正是你需要关掉音乐的时候。所以实际上我认为，针对不同情境策划你自己的播放列表是很重要的。与其只随机收藏一堆
of liked songs that you play whenever and that you kind of get bored of, think strategically. based on what we've discussed about music's impact on mood and arousal, create or find playlists that have the following vibes. So we're going to make five playlists. The first playlist is going to be a focus zone playlist. So this is your playlist for deep work. Think instrumental, lofi, ambient, classical music design to keep your mind engaged but not distracted.
喜欢的歌曲，在任何时候播放并开始感到厌烦，不如进行战略性的思考。根据我们之前讨论的音乐对情绪和唤醒度的影响，创建或寻找具有以下氛围的播放列表。所以我们要制作五个播放列表。第一个播放列表将是“专注区”播放列表。这是你进行深度工作的播放列表。可以考虑器乐、低保真（lo-fi）、氛围音乐、古典音乐，旨在让你的大脑保持专注而不是分心。
Then I want you to have the energy surge playlist. So you'll go to for workouts. before a big presentation or when you need to like shake off a slump. High tempo, driving beats, empowering lyrics. This is when you can consciously tap into that dopamine hit and that entrainment that we mentioned before as well to boost your physiological arousal. Then we want the calm down and center playlist. So gentle acoustics, nature sounds, classical pieces, slow jazz, designed to activate your
然后我希望你拥有一个“能量飙升”播放列表。这是你健身时的首选。在做盛大演讲前，或者当你需要摆脱低谷时。快节奏、强劲的节拍、赋能的歌词。这时你可以有意识地利用我们之前提到的多巴胺飙升和同频共振（entrainment）来提升你的生理唤醒度。接下来我们需要“平静与居中”播放列表。因此是温和的原声音乐、自然之声、古典乐曲、慢板爵士乐，旨在激活你的
parasympathetic nervous system, bring you back into your body. not necessarily the same as your deep work playlist. Then we want the process, My Feelings playlist. So this one is, you know, a playlist that has really deep cuts in it. It might even be like genuinely quite sad. But music that validates your emotions that provides catharsis makes you feel hopeful. Maybe we kind of divide this playlist into two. We have the process, my feelings playlist.
副交感神经系统，把你带回你的身体中。这不一定等同于你的深度工作播放列表。然后我们需要“处理我的情绪”播放列表。这个播放列表包含非常深刻的作品。它甚至可能真的很悲伤。但这些音乐能够验证你的情感、提供宣泄并让你看到希望。也许我们可以把这个播放列表分成两个。我们有“处理我的情绪”播放列表。
So this is like your really, really sad somber playlist. And then you have your like everyday background thinking fun lyric playlist. So music that like you can think about, music that you can sing along to, that is interesting to you and keeps you inquisitive and keeps you, yeah, curious, I guess. So leverage that. I want you to have those playlists so that you're not getting irritated by music. You're not finding that it's like slipping into context that it doesn't need to be in. I also think it's important to leverage music as a contextual.
所以这就像是你非常非常悲伤、忧郁的播放列表。然后你还有“日常背景思考趣味歌词”播放列表——也就是你可以思考的音乐，你可以跟着唱的音乐，它对你很有趣，能让你保持探究精神，并且让你，是的，保持好奇心。所以要好好利用这一点。我希望你拥有这些播放列表，这样你才不会被音乐激怒。你不会发现它溜进了不该出现的情境中。我也认为将音乐作为新习惯的上下文
cue for new habits. And this is, that's why the previous step is required that you have those playlists. This is a really cool trick from behavioral psychology. If you're trying to build a new habit, say meditating, journaling, getting ready for bed earlier, running, associate a specific type of music with that habit. Clay, the same calming instrumental piece every time you want to go to bed, every time you want to meditate, every time you wake up in the morning and you want to get up feeling excited. Over time, that music will become a conditioned stimulus. So it automatically signals to your brain to enter the specific state that you want to be in. It's creating a mental shortcut. I also think that given music's power, but also it's power to be a distraction like we were
线索加以利用是很重要的。这就是为什么需要前面的步骤——即你拥有那些播放列表。这是行为心理学中的一个绝妙小技巧。如果你想培养一个新习惯，比如冥想、写日记、早点准备睡觉、跑步，就把某种特定类型的音乐与那个习惯联系起来。每当你想睡觉时、每当你想冥想时、每当你在早晨醒来并想带着兴奋的心情起床时，就播放同一首舒缓的纯音乐。随着时间推移，这段音乐将成为一个条件刺激。所以它会自动向你的大脑发出信号，进入你想要进入的特定状态。这就是在创造一个心理捷径。我还认为，鉴于音乐的力量，以及正如我们之前讨论的那样，它也具有让人分心的能力，
talking about before, you do cord enough time in your day for silence. But you're not listening to a podcast. You're not listening to your music. You're not a music. You're not a immediately putting your headphones on, you're just embracing the sensory experience of the noises around you. Constantly playing music is actually probably interrupting your brain's ability to concentrate. And music will feel more special if you don't constantly have it in the background. Have you ever had this experience where you've been in meetings all the day, you've been running around all day or like all week and then you finally get to sit down and like put on your favorite album and you're like wow this actually this this stuff is good like this feels really nice
你需要在一天中留出足够的时间保持安静。你不听播客。你不听音乐。你不……你不是一回家就立刻戴上耳机，而是去拥抱周围噪音的感官体验。不断播放音乐实际上可能会打断你大脑集中注意力的能力。如果你不总是把音乐当背景音，音乐就会显得更特别。你有没有过这种经历：你一整天都在开会，一整天或者一整周都在奔波，然后你终于坐下来，放上你最喜欢的专辑，心想：哇，这东西真的……这东西真好，这感觉真好。
sometimes we actually do need to kind of let ourselves have a break from it or engage with music like beyond the headphones you know listen to it not through headphones listen to it in your car listen to it on your speaker system go to a concert go to karaoke go to a dance class so you experience what it's really meant to do for you, which is to connect you to others, connect you to your body, connect you to your environment as well, rather than just keep you quite insular, I guess. Just practice mindful listening, really listen to a song, really engage in it, really notice what it does for you, and really notice when perhaps it's frustrating you and you need silence. I think ultimately music is one of humanity's most profound
有时我们确实需要让自己从音乐中休息一下，或者超越耳机去接触音乐——比如不在耳机里听，在车里听，在音响系统上听，去听音乐会，去唱K，去上舞蹈课，这样你就能体验到它真正想要为你做的事，那就是将你与他人连接，将你与你的身体连接，也将你与你的环境连接，而不是让你变得孤立封闭。只需练习有意识地聆听，真正去听一首歌，真正投入其中，真正去注意它为你做了什么，并真正注意到它何时可能让你感到沮丧而你需要安静。我认为归根结底，音乐是人类最深奥的
gifts. Really, it is a gift. I'm feeling very spiritual about this episode, but I truly believe it is. Like, music is one of, I think, a lot of people's reasons for being. Like, a world without music would just be so terrible, and it's just so incredible
礼物之一。真的，这是一份礼物。对于这一期播客我感觉非常具有精神启迪，但我真的坚信如此。音乐是许多人生命的意义所在。一个没有音乐的世界将会是如此糟糕，而且它为我们的情绪、我们的治愈、我们的娱乐做出了如此巨大的贡献，这真是不可思议。它是至关重要的。它是强大的。它是心理上的伴侣。但要理解它的细微差别。带着意识与它互动，
how much it does for our emotions, for our healing, for entertainment. It's vital. It's powerful. It's a psychological companion. But understand its nuances. Engage with it. mindfully and harness its incredible mental power. So I think that's all I have time for today. I feel like we've covered a lot of bases. There's still things I probably didn't talk about.
并驾驭它那不可思议的心灵力量。我想我今天只有这么多时间了。我觉得我们已经涵盖了方方面面的内容。可能还有一些我没有谈到的事情。
But what I really want from you, if you have listened to this far, is to drop a comment below of your favorite song so I can make a playlist companion to this episode of the listener's favorite songs. If you are listening to this episode before, let's say, the 1st of July, 2025. Please leave a song down below. I want to make a little collaborative playlist of all our favorite songs. Also because I'm in kind of like a musical rap right now, I want to listen to some new stuff. Like I need to stop listening to the same like Kelsey Bellarini and like Vero Blue albums that I have been listening to on repeat. So put some song suggestions down below. I want to make this playlist happen. Thank you for listening this far. It will be a sign that you were able to
但我真正想要你做的是，如果你听到了这里，请在下方评论区留下你最喜欢的一首歌，这样我就可以为这一期播客制作一个听众最爱歌曲的伴随播放列表。如果你在2025年7月1日之前收听这期播客。请在下方留下歌名。我想制作一个包含我们所有人最爱歌曲的小型合作播放列表。也因为我目前正处于音乐的瓶颈期，我想听一些新东西。我需要停止循环播放我一直在听的凯尔西·巴勒里尼（Kelsea Ballerini）和维罗·布鲁（Vero Blue）的专辑。所以在下方留下一些歌曲建议吧。我想把这个播放列表做出来。感谢你收听到底。这表明你能够
concentrate and that you are a loyal listener. And also don't forget to follow me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcasts. Don't forget to listen to Mantra. If you want to break from your playlist, from your current albums on repeat, mantra is a really beautiful place to land. It is such a meditative podcast for me. It's such a great way to start your week. I will also have a link in the description as well.
集中注意力，而且你是一个忠实的听众。另外，别忘了在Instagram上关注我：@That Psychology Podcasts。别忘了收听《Mantra》。如果你想从你的播放列表、从你当前循环播放的专辑中抽离出来，《Mantra》是一个非常美妙的归宿。对我而言，它是一个极具冥想性的播客。它是开启一周的绝佳方式。我也会在简介中放一个链接。
Make sure you are following along. Make sure to give us a five-star review and share this episode with a friend. I'd love to hear your thoughts. feelings, quam's favorite, favorite songs in the comments or on Instagram. But until next time, stay safe. Be kind, be gentle to yourself. Happy listening. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking.
确保关注我们。记得给我们一个五星好评，并把这期播客分享给朋友。我很想在评论区或Instagram上听到你的想法、感受以及你最喜欢的歌曲。但直到下期节目之前，保重。善待他人，对自己温柔一点。祝你收听愉快。我们很快就会再聊。2%：这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在 我们这个奇异的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压力的科学。我将与
with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%.
作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等进行对话，看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield
这就是 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的《TWO%》。任何男人都应该遵守的两条金科玉律。第一条，绝对不要惹乡村女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖励。第二条，也绝对不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），
and in this new season of The Girlfriends Oh my God, this is the same man A group of women discover They've all dated the same prolific con artist I felt like I got hit by a truck I thought how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care So they take matters into their own hands
在《闺蜜》的新一季中：天啊，这就是同一个人！一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。
I said oh hell no I vowed I will be his last target He's gonna get what he deserves Listen to the Girlfriends Trust me babe on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我说，见鬼去吧！我发誓我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜：相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe）。还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 上双击小金姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金姆到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。在每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），畅谈80年代的可卡因。
To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备聊当天的可卡因，只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we,
是的。对我和美国历史上的黑人来说，这是最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们
are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
其实已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在继续追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要吗？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure,
你是个好人，是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和
and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
目标的真实对话。打开免费的 iHeart Radio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2%：这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇异的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
收听《2%》。这就是 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的《2%》。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和84年来说都是一个重大时刻。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。在每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kare Games.
和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。在它发生之前，那是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are honest? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct?
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人表现得像个硬汉却很诚实？这向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。而且仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控使人怀上双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alessian. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
我篡改了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱西亚（Greg Alessian）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。